welcome everyone to the may 2021 meetup
still virtual for the time being
hopefully not for too much longer
we are making some plans about that um
more details that come in the ensuing
months as hopefully the country starts
to safely open up
we'll we'll see how that goes folks um
but we have a lot of cool stuff
happening i'll go over all that overall
that
i will go over all that in our
announcements um as we get started
i just want to let the head count
stabilize a little bit i hope everyone's
having a wonderful
monday wherever you are um many of the
many different times those represented
where is everyone from actually
shout out where you're coming from
however yes yes perry we are going to
work
on a hybrid meetup actually in the past
but long before the pandemic
we actually live streamed a lot of the
meetups the problem was the audio was
terrible it worked great for the
recording afterwards but the live audio
was terrible we couldn't figure it out
but now that zoom has become so accepted
we are going to find a way to
continue doing hybrid this way people
can be in person and we'll have a
virtual component
as always all the videos are stored well
accessible
at nyhackguard.org they're actually on
the youtube page they can find them so
and you can search for them at
emilyhackguard.org there's some jankily
written search boxes
um chuck from brooklyn i love it do you
have a neighborhood in brooklyn
yeah it's a big bird
green point oh cool so hopefully you
have some poly g's pizza
they have the slice shop now i'm hoping
you're getting some some of that
and is it virtually interactive yes it's
the best we could do a virtual
interactivity but hopefully hopefully it
comes across um
ah chuck you know polly that's great yes
paulie is great
uh he um my friend had her uh wedding uh
rehearsal dinner there it was fantastic
uh we have someone from colorado but
formerly brooklyn i can't see
i just see your first name is end so i
actually can't see your eyes can you
switch that
ah no i know him and matt coming to us
from connecticut
uh you i do like colony grill in
stamford with the hot oil on it i think
that's
that's really great pizza man i've
you should go there oh yeah matt knows
that place because it's a great place
owned by a former hockey player so it's
even better
dave from connecticut oh yeah matt i've
been there a lot of times i love going
to colony girl
anytime passing through connecticut i
try to stop there
all right um yeah it's great so
we're going to do what we always do when
we get started first thing we do
is ask who is hybrid i know it's tough
here in virtual land because you can't
all just shout out
so folks if you are hiring you're
looking to get give someone a job
on the slack channel there's a slack
channel called job
dash postings if you want to get to our
slack we'll put it in here
the the link it's nytacr.org
slack.html
that's the same website where you can
find all the presentations
we have 12 years worth of slideshows up
there
and about eight years worth of videos
there's a lot of good information
and it's all sort of it now if you're
looking to hire someone
go to the job postings channel and post
a job
we've gotten so many people's jobs over
the years that we're really really
excited
about it we really like giving people
jobs um
speaking of hiring since i am
able to speak to everyone i get the to
announce some jobs we're hiring for
we are hiring for an account executive
but really looking for someone who's
more of a
technical person and the sales part is
less sales and more about
knowing the best things for customers
you want to get into data science sales
that's both software and services and
training
send me a message directly so you can
find me on slack i'm the um
or out of my car slack you can find me
at jerrylander.com you can find me
through meetup
folks you can find me just about
anywhere
we are also hiring for what i would
loosely call a sysadmin role
basically to maintain linux systems and
to do installations
uh like configuring software stuff like
that somebody's really good at batch
and understanding um security so if you
want to get a job
doing technical sales or managing linux
systems
send me a message i want to
thank ecohealth alliance for uh
sponsoring tonight for hosting us on
their zoom
uh they've been hosting us since last
april when it all started as
13 months ago great uh when it first
started actually gnome from ecohealth
alliance gave our first virtual talk of
the pandemic
discussing how to analyze covert data in
the spread
using epidemic epidemiological methods
uh so
thank you equal alliance for continuing
to host us here
um yes thank you perry clap clap clap
for uh for equal
alliance i know we can't be in person
but i just want to make sure everyone
has their pizza
mine today comes with a place called
intimos you see a good cheese lock
if you flip it around it has a little
bit grease on it that's some decent
charring
for those of you in chicago this is what
pizza looks like and from a profile
right you should be thinner than an inch
right so i hope everyone's enjoying
their pizza
if you got pizza from somewhere cool let
us know
we know that uh i think chuck had it
from paulie g's today
uh it was having pizza from anywhere
else cool recently or hopefully tonight
let us know jump in the chat and tell us
you got pizza it's your party's in west
haven
i haven't had the pleasure but hopefully
some of our other connecticut people
have finished the parties
anyone else had good pizza they want to
tell us about your freezer there's like
if you get table 87
it's actually really good freezer pizza
so freezer pizza might not be bad
depending where you go you've got
digiornos we'll talk later but if it's
you know table 87 it's pretty cool
all right uh so hope everyone just keep
trying as you go
now if you're looking to have a
conversation as we go forward
i highly recommend people go to the
slack team there's a channel
called um looking for the name of it oh
it's called
monthly meetup chat monthly meetup chat
if you go in there uh that's a great
place to talk about the meetup
tonight well in general but also about
tonight you have comments you have
questions
speaking of questions obviously we can't
all ask questions of james
let's go so if you have a question at
any point
put it in that slack channel the monthly
meetup chat slack channel
or right here in this
zoom chat window i will collate the
answer the questions and i will ask
james the questions at the end of the
talk
so please all the questions you might
have please go in there
and ask all the questions you want and
we will ask james on them towards the
end
i see um raman
is proud of his nyc style cross but
takes umbrage at my commentary
bring it i'm not ashamed of it i i'll
just i'll just bring it all together now
i will say
there are some good thing crested places
in chicago that are amazing and even p
quads has great deep dish um i like you
guys they have
what they call thin crust is kind of
thick but i think there's an appetizer
for their deep dish
right you gotta have both in one sitting
and you also have good bar pies in
chicago i'll give you that
all right so remember questions either
in zoom or at the slack channel
that perry just posted thank you very
much perry for helping out
um the meetup website that i pointed you
all to nyhackguard.org
has information about past meetups about
upcoming events
it's designed very poorly i designed it
it's written in our markdown which is
awesome but i designed it
it is open source it's at github.com
nyhakar
if anyone could do better and you
certainly can do better
make a pull request we will love to get
a pr you can tag yourself on the bottom
with your and you'll
tag you as a contributor please make a
pr make this better for the meetup
my team and i are trying to work on it
but we're trying to juggle so many other
things
make a pr make the website better for
everybody especially the presentations
page make it easier to search
i did that using the cross um the
crosstalk package
and data.table and it's it's interesting
so please let me know if you want to
help all right
um we have a bunch of announcements uh
that's coming up things coming up
we have our next three meetups planned
for
june july and august all right june 15th
is a meal pitfall i'm sorry emil if
you're here and i'm not pronouncing your
name correctly
um pitchfelt a lot of you know emil
on twitter uh speaking about text
processing on june 15th
that will be announced in a few days on
july
13th we have sean taylor of profit fame
an old member of the meetup from 10
years ago he's a member of the meetup
before he moved out west
uh sean will be talking july 13th on
topic to be determined
and on august 12th we have ian cook
talking about tidy query so august 12th
for ian cook
now the thing about two of those about
emil and about ian
they attended last month's meetup i saw
them in the chat and they
said i called them out by name told them
to email me to speak at the meetup and
now they're speaking this summer
all right so if you want to give a talk
send me a message with an idea
sometimes we plan six months in advance
sometimes you plan
two weeks in advance send me a message
and we'll see where you where you're
gonna fit in
it's gonna be a lot of fun next up we
have
july 14th through 16th right after that
next meet up
uh no two yeah no two and two meetups
it'll be two days after sean taylor's
talk
remember sean taylor you stand to do
profit we'll be having a stand workshop
i'm very excited we've been doing this
for six years now i believe i think we
started in 2015.
um every year we have a stand workshop a
three-day workshop
taught by the stan team it's being
taught by jonah gabriel
with rob trangucci and a third person to
be determined
and usually andrew gelman shows up and
hangs out and
chats with us during these workshops he
used to actually come for the full three
days
now he comes and gives his like expert
knowledge distilled down really quickly
those who have never seen andrew gilman
speak it is a delight
so come check that out july 14th through
16th
if you want to learn more we will be
sending an email out to the group if you
want to learn more we have not made that
a public yet so you want to learn more
about stan class we will be sending out
a email to everyone on the mailing list
the meetup mailing list about how to
attend the stand workshop
it's three days it's going to be all
virtual july we're still making it
virtual because
oh reopening it's we don't want to jump
and jump the gun here
so july 14-16 for a
um stand workshop three-day workshop
i've attended it six years in a row and
i keep learning something new every time
um my wife has been attending it and
actually that's one of the first things
before we mesh
emailed me about attending six years ago
so i'm going to have a real affinity for
this workshop
and if you want to attend when you
finally decide if you want a discount
20 off using the ny hackguard discount
and remember the proceeds go to
the spam language and open source and
programming so we really try to support
open source
and our last announcement before we
start is
well it's not a full announcement but we
have exciting news
about the new york r conference coming
out to you later this week
that's all i'm going to tell you but
stay tuned to your email the in my heck
our mailing list
for exciting information about the new
york art conference i'm wearing the
shirt by almost this one except this
shirt makes up
my wardrobe um those of you who've
attended you know how much fun it is
those of you who have not attended
you'll see how much fun it is again
stay tuned check your inboxes this week
we're gonna have some really cool news
for you i'm really really excited
uh we've been working really hard on
this uh on on what we're doing here
and i can't wait to tell everyone about
it but you have to wait a few more days
all right that's all my announcements
took a little longer than i usually do i
apologize for that
remember job postings questions in slack
and
zoom eat your pizza come to the next
meetups stay tuned for the conference
and come to the stand workshop
with that i have a speaker i'm very
excited about
i have been pestering him on github for
over a year now
about different feature requests
different things i want different
clarifications
getting stuff on the gpu getting stuff
done differently in r
all sorts of things and he has responded
to all my comments all my feature
requests
all my bug issues anything i've done
with a plum and with speed
and i'm very excited to have him give a
talk about
this package he's been working on
because it all started actually i think
over a year ago at the r conference i
want to give a talk
and include uh light gbm decided to make
some comments
and james and his team work really hard
to get it up crayon ready
and they do amazing stuff so everyone
please welcome
james for our speaker this month
everyone call uh virtual cloud
thank you so much happy to be here
very happy to have you don't don't stop
with the comments we really appreciate
it
absolutely i will i'll keep filling out
github issues
okay uh great yeah let's let's let's
rock
let me share my screen and we
are gonna get cracking okay uh you can
see my screen okay yeah
yes all right great let's do it let's
talk about
light gbm uh compared to other gradient
boosted decision tree libraries so
uh yeah there's gonna be a ton of stuff
here i think i could have made this like
a five hour talk but i stopped myself
short so please ask questions
and i'll do the best that i can to
answer them at the end so
uh yeah so my name is james lam i'm a
software engineer and data scientist
from chicago and i've been working as a
maintainer on the light gbm project
for i think four years now
more than three i don't i i'm not i
don't think it's five i think about
maybe four years maybe three i don't
know whatever uh you can reach me here
on github or on twitter
and i'll put all the contact stuff up at
the end let's go
right after it okay so the way that i'd
like to structure this talk
first i want to give you a really kind
of
good introduction to how the light gpmr
package works
and a little bit of you know what light
gpm is in general and how it works
um and so we're going to go through the
light gbm interface i'll show you
what the functions mean how to put them
together um
and then in the second half of the talk
we'll talk about comparing light gbm
to two of its peers that also have our
packages
and that's cat boost and xcabers so
let's get right into it oh i should say
i mean i'll say this at the end too
i'm going to be showing a bunch of
screenshots of code
all of that code is available on my
github you can see that i pushed the
last version of it 16 hours ago
uh if you go to github.com
and i'll put this link up later um you
can find this little r markdown
thing that has all of the code that
these screenshots are from so
you can you know either follow along or
try this
try this at home later all right let's
talk about
light gbm so light gbm is
a framework for handling supervised
learning types of tests
and i actually wrote this slide not even
knowing that pizza was like a whole meme
in this meetup so i'm really happy with
how that worked out
i mean you can use light gbm for a
couple different types of tasks for
binary classification you know zero one
type of classification
for multi-class classification or
learning to rank problems
um i spoke with a team at microsoft
maybe
i don't know six months ago or so and
there was this one kind of like
microsoft old timer who was telling me
about the origins of light gpm
light gpm's predecessor it's an internal
light uh microsoft project
was actually a learning to rank project
that was created for powering search
engines so you might see light gbm used
a lot in kaggle competitions for
classification and regression tasks but
its origins were
in uh learning to rank types of tasks
and then finally you can use light tbm
for regression problems
okay let's talk about the name light gbm
stands for light
weight gradient boosting machine and so
let's talk about
what that means um this project came out
of microsoft research
these papers i think are from 2016. i
always
when i give talks about light gpm i
always get to this slide and think
i really should have looked that up
again before i started um but but on the
order of five years ago
these papers came out light gpm highly
efficient gradient boosting decision
tree was the first one
and what these introduced was a method
for solving supervised learning problems
with trees and with gradient boosting so
this is sort of
a this this closely followed the
introduction of xg boost which is sort
of
the predecessor to this project and i
didn't want to assume in this talk
that everyone in the audience kind of
understood uh gradient boosting machines
and tree based gradient boosting so i
just want to briefly explain
what that means and how that works um
and that's what this little picture here
from this blog post gradient boosting
explained
is intended to do so ingredient boosting
you're building a forest of trees
to solve um a supervised learning type
of task
for this explanation let's just say it's
a regression task right where the goal
is to predict
some continuous value you might be
familiar with
other tree based methods like the random
forest for solving similar problems
and in the random forest type of method
right you train a bunch of trees
independently
each one's trained on a random subset of
the data and then your prediction
is averaging together the outputs of all
those trees
well that is not how gradient boosting
works ingredient boosting
trees are grown sequentially and so what
that means is when the modeling process
begins
you start with a beginning uh kind of a
beginning guess
beginning best guess at what the value
of the target will be for every record
for a regression test that might just be
like the mean
of the target across all the training
data something like that
then you train a tree and that tree is
trained on the residuals
between that first guess and the actual
values of the target
so that tree is going to learn basically
how to predict the residuals of the
model
up to that point then when you finish
growing that tree
you generate a new set of residuals
right so now your model is that original
guess
plus the prediction of that first string
the second tree is then trained on those
residuals this continues until the
boosting process ends and we'll talk
later about what it means for
the boosting process to end it's
actually a little complicated
but just keep that in mind as we go
through this that we're training trees
one at a time
and that the final output of the model
is given by adding the outputs of all
the individual trees
not by averaging or voting between them
or something like that
also keep in mind what it means uh what
it means to be a tree doesn't that sound
nice
what it means to be a tree right trees
look like this
they have uh circles and lines no they
have nodes and edges right so these
nodes
represent a split a split is a rule like
um you know feature abc
greater than five or something like that
and these lines to the left and right
say
data that are on one side you know the
greater than sign for example
and the data are that are on the other
side say the left-hand side
and the process of growing a tree means
adding these splits
one at a time so we're basically putting
together a bunch of rules
that describe how to map the input data
into a prediction about the target value
we'll talk about that more as we go
through the process here
okay light gbm you may know it as an r
package but it is not
purely an r package so the core logic of
light gpm you know the first
software that was written based on the
math in those papers
is in c plus and so in the light gbm
project we have the the kind of what we
call light gbm
core that's like uh or lib light gdm
that is
the the algorithmic core of light gbm
the boosting process the implementation
of different
loss functions and different metrics
different um
data transformations data like things
like that that's all written in c
plus and then in the project we have
a several other sort of interfaces into
that c plus plus code
written in other languages so we have uh
we actually have a cli
that's something that i didn't know
until i became a maintainer so
you can you know brew install light gpm
on your mac
um just like you installed git and do
training of machine learning models from
the terminal from a cli kind of cool
we have a python package we have a java
interface we have a project called
suede and we have an art package
and we also maintain two different
flavors of gpu acceleration
for all of these and then outside of the
light gpm project
there are a number of other rapper
libraries that we don't maintain
so you can train flight gpm models in
uh you know c sharp if that's your thing
or
um in spark with a project called mml
spark
and julia you know whatever you want
okay so let's talk about the programming
model for light gbm
um so when you do light gbm training
training in light gbm doesn't happen
directly on matrices
instead you create an object called a
data set
from a matrix and then training happens
on that
data set object so this is usually the
first place where people get tripped up
using light gdm and to be fair this is
an interface that actually boosts and
cap boost have as well
right in cap boost you create an object
called a pool in actually boost you
create an object called the d matrix
in light gbm we have the data set um i'm
going to explain next
sort of the process here and show you a
little bit of our code for doing this
but just keep in mind that this is what
we're aiming for raw data gets turned
into a light gbm data set
and it's that data set that we train on
and then
profit okay
so when you construct a data set the
data set is going to take your raw data
and do a bunch of pre-processing to get
that data ready for training
one of the first things that it'll do is
drop any features that are
unsplittable based on the parameters
that you've given
and so you may be used to this from
other machine learning work that you've
done right like it's a really common
thing
when you start working on a statistics
type of problem machine learning problem
to say okay i'm going to drop all my
near zero variance
features i'm going to say look because
this feature doesn't vary
a lot i'm not going to be able to get
much information
about the relationship between changes
in that feature and changes in the value
of the target so i'm just going to drop
that
in light gbm the dataset object doesn't
exactly have the same flavor of
near-zero variants it has this this
slightly different concept called min
data and leaf
and the way that min data and leaf works
is remember we had trees
right in each of these little circles is
a node
and some data maybe matches to that node
the nodes at the end you know where
there's no little lines coming out of
them
those are called leaf nodes and the leaf
nodes are where you get your predictions
right so like let's look at this this uh
filled in circle right here right
right here hopefully you can see my
cursor um
we've gone through two splits here and
we're saying okay like any data you know
where like
salary greater than a hundred thousand
and years of experience
less than 10 ends up in this circle
whatever
and then we're going to try to predict
like how many tabs that person has
opened
something like that and we're going to
do that maybe by taking the average
of all of the people who fall into this
note right
well think about that for a second like
in the most extreme
case we would grow these trees so deeply
that every leaf node matched exactly one
record right every there were so many
rules that every leaf node was like
a perfect description of one person
or one you know whatever in our data set
well as you can imagine right that's not
going to generalize
very well because you know in my example
of like
based on someone's salary and years of
experience how many tabs do they have
open
um you're going to find people in the
test set who
are different than the people in the
training set and it's like
you're not going to really feel very
confident with them matching to like a
rule that was so specific
that it only described one person in the
training game right
so that's the role of min data and leave
midnight and leaf says
light gpm will not create a split
that results in less than this many
observations
falling into a leaf note
and hopefully from this little thing
that i mocked up in google sheets
you can see how that is sort of the same
as saying
we're going to ignore near zero variance
features
right so consider this feature b that i
tried to you know kind of strike out
right
uh i have 10 observations here in my
training data
for 9 of the 10 observations this
feature has the same value
and for one of those observations that
has a different value well let's say i
was training with min data and leave
four
right saying each split has to describe
at least four records
i will never be able to find a split on
feature b
that satisfies them right if i do
a split that's like greater than 50.8
then we're going to have 10 records in
one leaf
and zero records in the other that's not
bound
if i do any other split between 1.2 and
50.8
say like greater than 1.2 then we're
gonna end up with nine records in one
leaf node
and one in the other this is not going
to work right and so instead of going
through all of its other pre-processing
light gbm is gonna say oh
well you don't like this i already know
i cannot do anything with this feature
i'm just gonna drop it right now uh to
save memory and to save computing time
as i do other
processing all right next light gbm is
going to discretize your continuous
features
so when you're looking for through a
tree based model right um
each these nodes are added one at a time
and the most
expensive part of the process is this
process of
determining which node to add next
and so you go through over and over
again you add a node then you recompute
add again right
and the more possible splits you have to
search
the longer this takes and so anything
that you can do
to reduce the number of splits that you
try
without having a large sort of negative
impact on the model's performance
that's going to be a win because you're
going to speed up training and still get
a good model
that's why light gbm uses this uh thing
called the histogram approach
and this is now available in actually
boost by the way as well but it's been
the default in light gbm from the
beginning
so light gpm is going to say okay i have
this feature with these values 2
3 5 9 11 12 16. well i don't want to
check
these splits that are like greater than
2 greater than 3 greater than 5 etc etc
instead i'm going to bucket this feature
into a histogram
um using an algorithm that is described
in the paper
and what i'm going to say is the only
splits that i'm going to consider the
only candidates for those new nodes
are going to be the boundaries between
the bins and the histogram so i'm saying
basically like this part of the
distribution
all of these values they might as well
be the same for the purpose of this
model
and what we found in light gbm and what
what you know many practitioners have
found
is that this does speed up the training
process significantly and
in many cases you don't end up losing
very much predictive power or
information
and this can be controlled by a number
of different parameters
um the one that i think is most
important to think about are these max
bin parameters which say basically like
think about whenever you've made a
histogram in r right and you control the
the number of bins like increasing the
number of bins
means you have more boundaries that
means you lose
less information the model should
perform better but
training time will slow down decreasing
the max bin says i'm going to get a
coarser representation of the
distribution
but training will go faster and it's
sort of a model and data specific
question where to make that trade-off
between getting more iterations
in the same amount of time or getting a
better
um sort of statistical output a better
predictive power
from however many iterations you can get
done interesting to think about
another thing that the data set will do
is something called exclusive feature
bundling
so this is light gbm's answer to sparse
features
this is another opportunity to reduce
the number of split points
that light uvm has to consider and it
works like this
so um when i say sparse features what
that means is basically
when one feature if one feature when
it's zero
the other feature is always non-zero
then there is some relationship there
right
and the sparsity comes from the fact
that there are many zeros here
well light gbm uses this trick where it
says okay
in this sort of perfect case i can
combine these two features into one new
feature
decreasing the number of split sides to
consider without reducing without losing
any information
right so if you look at this feature
bundle feature you can see that the
values
when feature one was non-zero are the
feature one values right one two three
four one two three four
and the values when feature one was zero
are the feature two values plus the
maximum of feature one
right so two plus four is six one plus
four is five
and so what that means is if you look at
the distribution of this feature bundle
you can imagine like drawing a vertical
line and saying
to the left of this is the values from
feature one to the right of this is the
values from feature two
but by treating this as one numeric
feature we've now reduced the number of
split points
and we've given light gbm the
opportunity to learn sort of like
spillover types of splits right so if
flight gpm learned a split that was like
a feature bundle greater than five
that's basically saying
feature one is non-zero or feature two
is a small value
it's kind of cool right and so all of
that is going to be done in the
construction of the data set
object and so what you should expect is
especially based on
you know based on all three of these
things right dropping features that are
not going to be useful
um reducing the space of the training
data into these bins
which you can imagine just representing
basically by by integers and like a
floating point value for the threshold
and condensing sparse features the data
set object is going to be smaller
than the raw data in matrix form and
training is going to be faster
because all training uses these sort of
this sort of histogram representation
of the data so let's see what that looks
like in r
um in our so here i'm going to use the
weather data set from the nyc flights 13
um package i actually genuinely like
that package and i'm not
pandering but i guess that that works
well
so this is a data set that has some
different data collected from
um from from uh
airports i think i don't remember
exactly what the details are um but one
of these are weather observations so
their observations of things like
temperature the the
wind direction wind speed stuff like
that and in the examples i've created
for this talk
we're going to solve the regression
problem of predicting
humidity based on observations of
um the other weather observations and
this is the type of problem that i've
worked on in the past you know like
if you can build a model of one sensor
based on the values of other sensors
that might give you a hint towards
building some sort of anomaly detection
system
that can catch sensor errors right where
you can say like
yeah even though the value from this
this sensor is normal
based on its distribution uh it's not
really normal based on
everything else that's happening around
something like that and so what you're
going to do in light gbm
um you know in this case i have data in
a data.table i'm going to convert this
to a numeric matrix
and then pass that data into the
lgb.dataset function
so the lgbt.dataset produces a light jbm
dataset
object that's an r6 object um
but what really happens inside there is
on the c
plus side we create a data set object
using light gpm c
plus plus library and then this r6
object
just contains basically like a pointer
to the head
of that object uh to be used by c
and you can see in the interface here
we're splitting up the
the feature data which i've called x
train and the label
data which i've called y train um
another thing that's confusing i think
sometimes when people start with light
gbm or with some of its peers
is the use of the word label so um the
use of the word label this happens
throughout
the light gbm interface even for a
regression problem like this one
the word label refers to the target so
for me it was like a little weird at
first to think of a continuous valued
thing
as a label and not as like target but
trust me like we're doing we're doing
regression in this example
and then finally the the data set object
doesn't require column names
strictly it just requires a matrix that
can work with sort of column indices
but you can optionally provide a vector
of feature names
and then some other operations become a
little nicer you can
indicate other things by name um you can
get some names to show up on like plots
and tables and things like that
so this is going to be the data um the
data
setup step for light gbm
okay once your data are in a dataset
object
you have two options for training this
is another place where people
or people get tripped up is that there's
basically two functions to accomplish
the same thing
and that is lgb.train and the light gbm
function they're very very similar
the biggest difference is that lgb.train
it is a little bit stricter and it does
a little bit less for you
magically so in lgb.train you have to
have
already created your
dataset object and then you come with
that and you say here's my dataset
object
in light gpm you can come with them with
a
r matrix for the data and for the target
and then this this function will create
a data set object for you
similarly the light gbm function by
default is going to save the model to a
text file at the end of training
whereas lgb.train is not going to do
that you'd have to do that manual
so i personally when i do work in light
gbm i prefer
lgb.train just because it's a little bit
more predictable and a little bit
stricter but
both will accomplish can be used to
accomplish all the same things
let's go further in the training process
so now we've got our data it's in the
light gbm data set object and we're like
ready to start training
right let's talk about what the training
process is going to do so remember i
said that
i kind of like waved my hands and was
like yeah we built trees there's circles
and lines right
well how does any tree based algorithm
add those circles how does it decide
uh it does that by evaluating many
different splits
and then choosing the one that has the
largest gain and so gain
basically means what will give me the
largest
improvement on whatever objective
function i've defined
that i'm trying to optimize sometimes
instead of objective function the phrase
loss function is used it's the same
thing light gbm comes with a bunch
of objectives built in and
choosing your objective will change the
model um
that's produced right like that's
expected so for example it will matter
whether you choose an l2 loss or an l1
loss
for regression application right if you
choose l2 loss
you're basically choosing to put a
higher weight on
large model errors because those errors
are getting squared as an example
and so you can go to the light gpm
parameter documentation
and there are all these examples of the
different built-in
objectives i want to stop here and say
if you know c plus and statistics
and you see sort of a common
supervised learning loss function you
know there's one that you really like
that isn't here
we would love if you come talk to us
about contributing it we we would really
appreciate that
okay but let's say that you don't want
to write s equals plus
but you do want to do special things
with your objective function
maybe you know i i've seen for example
um businesses that create their own
objective functions with
business logic inside the training
function right so they'll say like
we want to guarantee that uh you know we
want to put higher weight
on getting this prediction right for our
premium customers or you know whatever
all kinds of stuff
well you can do that in light gpm so in
light gpm's our package
you can come with an r function and that
will be used to guide the training
process
so at each at each boosting iteration
during the training process
instead of using one of light gpm's
built-in metrics
instead from the r package light gpm is
going to
basically supply to this function the
current predictions of the model up to
this point
and the training data and this model and
this function is responsible for
producing two outputs
uh basically a matrix of gradients and
the hessian matrix this is like the
the first derivative of the loss
function and the second derivative of
the loss function
so in this example i made sort of like a
very kind of simple kind of silly
example
um for l2 loss the hessian is constant
the gradient is just like sort of like
the l1 loss right it's like the uh
the difference the direct difference
between the predictions and the target
and then i've just added this extra
little thing where i'm going to call
praise praise
so that every boosting round lycheevam
is going to tell me that i'm doing great
so that i don't get sad and think that
my model is bad
but you can do much more complicated and
interesting things than this kind of
like
joke one
um okay and yeah let's keep going on
slide stuff sounds great
um okay let's talk about how you know i
mentioned
before like oh yeah you keep doing this
and then training ends right
let's talk about what it means for
training to end so
first within the growth of a tree tree
growth is going to stop when a tree
specific stopping condition is met there
are a bunch of these that are
controllable by parameters
so for example in light gbm you can
control the total number of leaves in
the tree
this is a way to limit complexity you
can think of this as like a measure to
prevent overfitting right
so if if light gbm just added another
um you know another split that added
another two leaf nodes
and now that pushed it you know right to
this limit like gbm is going to say
great this tree is done
time to move on you can also limit the
depth of the tree and so that is like
basically the number of lines that it
takes to get from a leaf node
from the furthest down leaf node all the
way back to the root
you saw our friend mind data and leaf
earlier so i won't go over that again
and you can also specify this parameter
min gain to split
which says okay when you're looking at
these objective functions
and you're considering a split don't add
another
node unless it gives me at least much
this much you know this number
improvement
in that loss function and so this is
another way to limit complexity and to
say like
i don't want you to train a fairly
complicated model kind of fiddling
around at the edges i'd rather have
something that's simpler and hopefully
more generalizable as a result
okay so so this is like how to decide
whether or not to stop growing one tree
the training process altogether stops on
what i call
model-wide stopping conditions and there
are two that i think are useful to know
one is the number of iterations and this
is exactly what you think it is
if you use num iterations 100 this says
light gbm
train 100 trees you can prevent that
in every gradient in many gradient
boosting libraries
using something called early stopping
and what early stopping says
is okay okay i know you want to go to
100 trees
but i'm going to give you a holdout set
and some metrics to evaluate
after each boosting round eval
basically predict on those holdout sets
calculate these metrics
and then over the rounds keep track of
those metrics
and if the metrics that i gave you don't
improve
over a certain number of consecutive
rounds then just conclude like you know
what
we've gotten what we're going to get out
of this let's stop the training process
right now
so either two of those conditions could
stop training
and then your model is done
okay and and to do that you're gonna
pass a validation data set
um as another use of a validation data
set you can do this just to basically
keep track of metrics and get them
printed to see what's happening during
training
even if you don't want to do early
stopping and validation data sets are
created with this function
lgb.dataset.create.value
it's important that these data sets not
be matrices but that they be light gpm
dataset objects
because you want to be sure that they
went through the same pre-processing you
know you want to be sure that
those features that were dropped the um
you know the combination with the
bundling of sparse features stuff like
that
but that was done exactly the same you
can pass as many of these as you want to
light gbm
using a list of them um and then you can
also pass and pass in as many metrics as
you want to be evaluated
and what you see in these logs on the
right hand side is basically the
evaluation of those metrics
uh every 10 iterations so in this case i
set this parameter eval freak equals 10
to say
okay don't print this every time just
tell me every time and you can kind of
it's kind of fun to watch honestly like
you can see what's happening here right
after one tree was trained uh this
model's mean absolute error you know
the l1 was 14.8 then that was basically
cut in half
10 iterations later you can see this
starting to like
really really slow down right so you can
provide multiple evaluation metrics here
if you'd like
there are a bunch listed at this light
at this light gbm
documentation site so in this small bit
of example code right i've said okay
here's my training data
train for 100 iterations um the the
objective that i'm trying to optimize is
l2 loss
i'm going to give you this hold out data
set print these results every 10
iterations
and then i've said give me the mean
absolute error the root mean squared
error
and the mean absolute percent error and
light gbm is going to print all of those
as we go
um and you can see you know maybe based
on looking at those metrics
what's what's going on you can get a
hint into like what sorts of errors are
being made
just like with objective functions the
light gbm
r package also allows you to write your
own
metric functions in r so for example
light gbm doesn't have
a median absolute error right so i wrote
up this little example of median
absolute error
um hopefully from like an r code
perspective this shouldn't look too
scary
this takes in a dataset object and a
vector of predictions
and the median absolute error is going
to be taken by getting the absolute
value of the difference between
the prediction and the actual and then
taking the medians right
and what you can see is i can provide
that to this argument eval
and light gbm after every iteration or
in this case every 10 iterations because
i set eval freak
is going to call my function on the
training data and the predictions
and then we're going to get this nice
kind of trace of the metrics
and it is interesting to see right like
seeing this gap
between the median absolute error and
the mean absolute error
maybe that tells you something about how
many you know how many
large errors we're making or at least
the presence of some
fairly large errors this is like a you
know maybe a maybe a meaningful
uh difference and you can imagine doing
this with whatever right like
again if you have business like business
logic specific
things you want to do like how well is
this model performing
on new customers or something like that
uh you can you can slam that right into
light gbm
with the custom metric function
okay after training you can access all
these evaluation results um
using the record evals property so
training produces an
r6 object do i not have that in the
slide oh it's a couple slides down
training produces an r6 object called a
booster
and this property record evals is one of
the properties of the booster so
you can see from my example here with
the three metrics
that i'm going to get this list of you
know my l1 my rmse my mape
and then evaluate it and then like the
full vector sort of
evaluations at each iteration and so
then you can use this to do your own
custom
post-processing making plots you know
like
whatever makes you happy okay
as i mentioned before you can speed up
training a lot using something called
early stopping
and so to enable early stopping in the r
package you have to provide
three things you have to provide a
validation set
which is just another light gbm dataset
object we talked about that before you
have to provide one or more metrics
and then you have to provide this
parameter early stopping round and early
stopping round
says okay if this metric
evaluated on the validation set
does not improve for three consecutive
iterations
then just stop training like i'm done
we're
we're good on this and that's what
happened here right so
um when i went through this training run
excuse me
um what we saw here was uh basically
that
excuse me uh one of these metrics failed
to fail to improve for three consecutive
iterations and so even though i asked
for 100 training rounds
training stopped after 81 rounds this is
also very
uh very freeing because when you do grid
searches or whatever
you don't need to worry about setting
very large values of
you know 10 rounds because you can rely
on early stopping to catch you
if those values are ridiculous you don't
have to wait for training to end
um and i think that this plot you know
this is a real plot with the trace of
the median absolute error remember my my
custom metric
uh evaluated on this validation set in
this case this was in
out of time validation set i trained on
january through november november
and held out december you can see that
after like i don't know 30 iterations
we're really not getting a lot of
improvement in this metric um
and so you can see like if i had gone to
like 500 iterations
probably wouldn't have been worth the
time okay
um right and so you can call predict on
these
on the model object just like you're
used to in other r libraries
um there's a predict s3 method
implemented basically you just say
predict of model on some testing data
that testing data should be a matrix
it should not be a light gpm dataset
object
the model object will contain kind of
all of the transformations needed
to do these predictions you know put it
into the right histogram bins et cetera
et cetera
and then you just get a vector of
predictions just like you know
predicting from an lm object in our
or something like that okay
um the booster mod the booster object
can be saved and loaded
in a bunch of different formats so um if
you want to inspect the model in json
format you can dump it to json
you know you can use json lite to read
that into a list
um we don't currently support loading
models from that json format but
um some people have found that that's
useful for doing things like
storing the model details in a
document-based data store like a um
in elasticsearch or something like that
and categorizing you know
experiments something like that you can
write the model to a string so light gbm
has its own
sort of text format for light tbm models
you can dump that into a string in
memory
and then create a new boost logic by
loading from that string
you can create a text file with that
string and pass that around
and you'll be able to read that back up
into a booster and you know start again
so you might for example
um go through training save this string
to an object store like s3
azure blob store and then your
deployment path might look like
pulling down that file creating a
booster from it and you know
starting to score and then you can also
save and load these objects with save
rds and load rds
this will not work today with the
built-in save rds and load rds and
that's just based on
the way that the r package handles those
sort of pointers to objects created in c
plus plus like i talked about before um
but thankfully we've had one
very active um sort of member of our
community
creating a bunch of issues recently
describing in like pretty good detail
what would have to be done
to support just like regular old save
rds and load rds so
that is coming
okay um and then i won't belabor this
but you can dump these models into a
data frame
if you want to look at the structure so
this decision type is explaining
um basically one split point right so
like think about this
this is saying like okay we had a split
that was chosen in this tree
for temperature less than or equal to
43.07
or we had a categorical split that was
like our
equals basically from hour 9 to 19 of
the day
something like that um there's tons of
other stuff you can do with this
i i won't belabor that point i want to
be sure we get to
the other sort of comparison type of
details
and then light gpm um i think this is
the last okay
the light gpm art package comes with a
function called lgb.cv
um this is extremely similar to the cv
function
in xg boost if you've ever used that
that can be used for
uh cross validate you know k-fold
cross-validation
generally um and for the application of
hyper-parameter tuning specifically so
this is sort of a minimal example of
tuning light gbm parameters
um through a couple of different
training runs where what you'll do is
you'll provide to lgb.cv
on a light ubm dataset object your
objective
any other light gbm parameters that you
want
and then a number of folds it'll go
through and basically
um create that number of folds do k-fold
cross-validation
and then it'll spit back out to you an
object called a cd booster
that includes this parameter best score
which means basically like
how well on average did um
did models trained with this set of
parameters perform
on their holdout sets basically uh and
you can use that to sort of do
hyperparameter
hyper parameter tuning we don't really
have any
sort of first class integrations today
with anything else in the r ecosystem
that people use for hyper parameter
tuning so
if you have ideas about that we would
love to hear uh
you know a proposal on an issue of you
know an interface that you'd like to see
or something that that you feel would be
easier by integrating with another
library
okay let's talk about cap boost and ice
tables
so i just want to be clear this is the
part of the talk that i'm least sure
about
i'm much more familiar with light gpm
than i am with these other two projects
but
i did do a lot of research and hopefully
hopefully i'm right about this but but
please correct me in the q
a if i say anything that's wrong or
that's misleading
okay first there's a lot of similarities
between these projects
all of them support early stopping all
of them support
something called weighted training which
just basically means
in any process that samples the training
samples
certain samples can be given a higher
likelihood of being chosen
in those random sampling processes
that's basically what that means
um all of them support boosting from an
original score an initial score
so remember i said the boosting process
is like start with the best first guess
then learn the residuals
then learn the residuals from that et
cetera et cetera right well this initial
score thing is extremely powerful
because you can say i'm not just going
to guess that you know for a regression
problem
the initial score is the average of the
target i have some other model that i'm
going to run
i'm going to get the predictions from
that model i'm going to tell light gbm
hey
this is my initial guess and then boost
off of that
and see if light gbm can improve that
other model
that linear model that you know maybe
some heuristics whatever
and then all of them are tree based
algorithms and so all of them support
controlling the model complexity by
doing things like limiting the number
of leaves or limiting the max step
um okay so unlike light gpm and cat and
actually boost
if you work with cap boost you are not
going to be able to write your own
objective function or metrics functions
in r
although they're looking for someone to
help them with that
in cat boost um their handling of
categorical features is kind of like the
shining feature of cat boost the thing
that's really powerful
it's literally what cat in catboo stands
for and what they do is something called
ordered target encodings i'm not going
to go into this
in detail you know just in the interest
of time but i really recommend that you
watch this talk um this talk from
this talk is from one of the developers
from cat boost um and in that talk he
describes
this method but effectively you know if
you're taking the categorical variable
and you're trying to do target encoding
right you're trying to say like
turn the categories into like the mean
of the target for that category or
something like that
instead of doing that based on that mean
over the entire data set
cap boost is going to do that
iteratively it creates this artificial
sort of
timing in the data set and so it's going
to say like
my encoding of you know this value ste
is based on the values of the target
when this
this feature was equal to sde only for
the records
sort of before this one it's really
really cool i recommend you check it out
light gpm does not have that although
there has been
a long running pr in light you've got to
add it for a while so
maybe one day okay um cat boost will
also
test combinations of categoricals which
is cool so
if you have a categorical feature like
genre and another one like musical style
cat boost will automatically test the
combination of those right so like the
genre plus style combinations
light gpm does not do that
in cat boost you can come with features
that are text which is wild to me
you can just say like here's a sentence
kappu's like try to vectorize it try to
create these other numeric
representations of it light gbm
is not going to do that
um let's talk about tree growth so cad
boost uses this really interesting thing
called
symmetric trees so if you notice in this
diagram that i
crudely created in google slides these
splits are identical
right uh feature eight greater than 2.3
greater than 2.3 etcetera etcetera
and so after this initial split whenever
a split is added at one level of the
tree it's added at all of
like for all uh basically under all it's
basically one level is all the same
split all the way across
you might find that that's interesting
for your problems
in xg boost they grow something called
depth wise trees and so in depth wise
what happens is um you're not going to
have sort of
lopsided trees like you're not going to
have
you know after this sort of left hand
side split the next thing that will
happen
is either this right hand side split or
nothing
um by default now in exchange boost and
in capitals you can customize this but
but that's the default
and so those two libraries tend to grow
more balanced
trees they sort of like put some
emphasis on describing both sides of an
initial split
not the case in lgbm in light gbm uh
trees are grown in what's called a lost
guided or leaf wise method
which means basically at each individual
point
light gbm will decide to add the split
that has the largest impact on the loss
function the largest gain
regardless of how how deep that split is
added and so what that means is you
might end up with these fairly like
sort of lopsided trees that are deep
down one side and shallow on the other
keep that in mind as you think about how
to use parameters like max
depth that you might be familiar with
using from sort of symmetric
uh types of libraries
um and then finally i think this is the
last ever okay and then finally
until very recently you could not use
categorical variables directly in extra
groups
so until recently um in actually boost
you had to handle
numeric encoding of your categoricals
you had to decide like
am i going to do targeting coding am i
going to do one hot am i going to do
something fancier um as of release 1.3
which was the
they're currently on the 1.4 series so
it was uh i think
yeah december 2020. um xgboost now has
some
support for categoricals but if you have
a lot of categorical data
i think you'll probably find that you
have a better experience with cat boost
or with flight gpm
okay the last thing that i want to go
through i want to spend like you know
three minutes
four minutes on are some of these kind
of uh
software comparisons between light light
gbm
and cap boost and actually so we've
talked a lot about
the algorithmic details of these three
libraries about the library interfaces
i want to talk about some of the other
sort of like things that you have to
think about
when you choose to use software
so first i did not reinvent doing any
sort of benchmarking in terms of time
memory usage anything like that zeolar
pavka has an amazing
amazing set of benchmarks that are
maintained they're all dockerized and
unbelievable you definitely should check
them out at this at
this repo uh z large size gbm perf
and broadly what those benchmarks have
shown and i hope that i'm not
misrepresenting
is you should expect xg boost to perform
better
on the gpu you should expect xc boost
right now to
utilize the gpu more fully to give you a
lot faster training
um but you should expect that light gpm
will train faster on cpu
broadly for large-ish data sets
you know on the order of tens of
millions of rows um
and that lychee beyond actually boosting
capos will broadly give you
somewhat comparable performance these
are all very squishy terms right like
it's always horrible when you see
benchmarks in a conference talk because
there's always more wrong about them
than right
but i really really encourage you to
check out these benchmarks
that zeal artists put together there's a
ton of information in there
and i think you'll find it useful but
for sure you should not walk away from
this talk thinking like
oh light gbm is faster than actually
lose period
or like oh cat boost is always going to
perform better with categorical features
period
the story is a lot a lot more
complicated than that
um and and here's another example of
that from the same repo um
there are a lot of details in here that
you can get into you know how well is
the project maintained
um does it work on does it have gpu
optimizations like how good is the gpu
project i have nothing else to say about
this table you should check it out
okay a big big big selling point that i
think favors light gbm and xg boost
is that you can install light gbm and
actually boost from cramp
um cam boost is not on cran they did
attempt a submission i believe a year
and a half ago
um i've been subscribed to the issue
where they're tracking the work for that
but
i don't think it's an active point of
focus for the developers there right now
so um you're gonna be using you know
remotes install github or something like
that
to install capos and that comes with all
the other sort of downsides of not being
on cran
you're not going to get pre-built
binaries um they won't have been tested
on sort of more exotic systems
older versions of r newer development
versions of r et cetera
um okay let's talk about release
frequency so when you find and find
report and or fix a bug
how long can you expect it to take for
that to get into a release
um cap boost and xg boost are doing a
better job with this than we are in
lightshive to be honest
broadly speaking you can expect cap
boost and xc boost to be released
every two to three weeks late gbm is
released every two to three months and
that's
i'd be happy to answer a question about
that in q a but i won't i won't belabor
that point
um xc boost supports the widest range of
our version so i remember working in a
large old slow moving company
where i didn't have admin on my laptop
and i had to get sort of like a
an i.t help desk that was just like a
sort of a black box that i sent emails
to i didn't know
how to contact them i didn't have any
faces there you know i didn't know
anybody
i remember being in a situation where i
had asked them to install software for
me
and at any time i was like at least two
years behind
the published version of r so this is a
very real situation that i know people
face
cap boost does not declare a dependency
like a floor for r
in their package description file and
they don't have any publicly visible
continuous integration or notes in their
documentation so i have no idea what
versions of our cap boost is supported
for
for light gbm uh lightsaber will work
with r 3.6 and up
and for actually boost it'll work with
3.3 and up
okay i mentioned before that to work
with these libraries right
you have to take data that's in like a
matrix or some other format
and read it into their special kind of
uh
data format right i believe
i feel like 95 confident in this table
that i've created please correct me if
any of it is wrong
you can come to all three of these
libraries with the library's own binary
format for data sets
with you know tab separated files csvs
with lib svm files
or with a base r numeric matrix
light gbm and xg boost will support um
csr sparse matrices using the matrix
package
cap boost does not as far as i can tell
cap boost allows you to create a pool
from a data frame directly
as of today light gbm and xg boost do
not although we have a feature request
out for that my gbm right now with a lot
of good details
um i expect that that feature might make
it into the next
light gbm release we'll see but for now
um
you know if you have data frames you
have to do a little bit more work
before you can use light gbm and
actually boost
okay i have two more things to tell you
about these libraries and we'll open it
up for q a
cap boost has the fewest dependencies of
these three projects
whether you consider depends depends on
imports or depends imports and suggests
um their only imports level dependency i
believe
is json light maybe there's one other i
think it's just json light
and then it's recursive dependencies
could be wrong about that um
so if that matters to you a lot you know
if you're building a package
that extends one of these projects you
might need to care about building
all of their suggests dependencies this
number can get pretty big
very quickly um and i've included some
code
in the repo for this talk that shows you
how i calculated these numbers
using another project i've worked on
called packagenet and by the way
there's code in the repo for this
release stuff as well
and then finally the last thing that i
want to tell you about these libraries
all i'm saying is light gpm is the only
one with a hex logo
so do what you want with that
information personally i think that's
the only one that would that
i personally i think that means we're
the only ones that are taking
r seriously but draw your own
conclusions
um and with that i i like to open up for
questions
thank you for your time um please please
please
if you're interested in contributing to
light gpm come consider you know
come open issues um come comment on the
open issues there
come ask us we will give you work to do
i promise
message me on twitter like i will give
you work to do if you're interested in
light gpm
and interested in r um and with that i
will open it up for q a
i'll start a uh virtual applause that
was terrific
you're getting a golf clap because um i
don't want the the microphone to go
crazy
i see some people are clapping in the
chat window uh
first that hex sticker indictment it was
perfect
i think that perfectly spells it all
right there
thank you thank you appreciate that yep
uh so as people have more questions you
can ask either here and zoom or in
slack and i have a bunch of questions
already collated
um over here on my other screen uh so
i'll start diving in
um early on you talk about future bundle
is that like
pca in any way because you're taking
multiple variables and condensing it
down to fewer
that's a great question it's different
so the exclusive feature bundling is a
little bit different from pca
in the sense that what we're not trying
to do is say like
create some linear combination of
features it's much like
uh i don't want to say dumber than that
it's much coarser than that right it's
like
literally when this one thing is not
zero the other thing is zero and vice
versa
what if we just stack them so there
could
to answer what i think the underlying
question is there you might still find
that creating
that using pca as a pre-processing step
to create features
might be valuable and might improve the
performance of light tdm
okay cool uh
next we have can light gbm do linear
boosting like gb linear and xg boost
um that's a good question so we do have
a feature in light tbm where
at each at each leaf node
the prediction from that leaf node is
not going to be like the average of the
target
it will actually be the prediction of a
linear model like cubist kind of right
i'm not familiar with that cubist is
like i think it's sort of like
a um i think it's a similar random
forest but the nodes are
linear models i think oh interesting
yeah well that is
that what those words you just said
describe the linear the linear trees
feature in light gdm
which is new within the last um than the
last year or so so there's a parameter
you can set it's literally like
linear tree equals true and at each leaf
node you're going to get the prediction
from a simple linear model
instead of um sort of like that
that simpler like minimize the objective
function type of prediction
i'm going to follow up on their pressure
a little more on that um when you get to
those leap nodes and it fits a simple
linear model
what's the x variable assuming it's a
simple linear model is the one x
variable what is that
i okay i'm going to tell you what i
think how i think it works
let me just let me just tell you
something before i tell you i think
that's right
let me tell you how i became a
lightsaber maintainer okay
i don't have a phd in statistics or
machine learning
nor do i know those things at the level
that's all the phd in the past
i just like really understood rcmd check
and
i just did all the like annoying stuff
that they didn't want to do
and after a while they were like do you
want to just keep doing this stuff
because we don't want to do it
and i did it um so i like
with that big caveat that like my
understanding of statistics is probably
below the median
of people in this meetup right now i
will tell you that what i think is
happening
is that the splitting is happening in
the way that lychee beam always does
splits
so where like your x right is the future
that was split on
and it's just the prediction at the very
end that is being changed
i think but i don't i don't know for
sure
all right um then i'm going to press you
a little bit more on that one since
there's actually one that's actually
it's um that the theme is what the
person was trying to get at
um like with xg boost instead of fitting
a tree with like linear models in the
nodes
it actually just fits a straight up
linear regression like lm would do but
it boosts it
so you actually can get coefficients you
know that you actually get the absolute
value of coefficients
but you get coefficients from a literal
linear model
some do you know if let you do anything
like that oh interesting
i i'm not aware of the ability to do
that in my gpm
okay that being said being able to write
your own objective function in r
opens you up to do like a lot of stuff
you know but i i'm not aware of anyone
having done that in my tbr
okay i think also um the gbm package
originally from um
i think it's hasty and efron and using
tripiani
uh that can do both trees and linear
models but it's a completely different
ball game than
these all these all these great
interested algorithms yeah for sure
there is
um i can't say yes i don't
i don't i'm not familiar with there
being like a literally train a linear
model
right situation right the only
customization that i
i'm aware of that would feel really
different from other boosting
is random forest mode where you're
basically using the light gbm kind of
mechanics of like the feature bundling
and
all that other stuff but you're not
really boosting
like right you're just choosing random
subset of the data at each tree and then
you're like doing random forest stuff
okay well since you brought that up i'm
asking my own question then
um in xg boost they have that
experimental feature numb parallel trees
all right and what you could do there
you it is sort of like the pseudo-random
forest
uh because instead of doing the sampling
at each split
it does the sampling at the tree level
all right so two questions
one is your random forest mode a true
random forest or is it a pseudo random
forest and b
in sg boost you could actually do a
boosted pseudo-random forest
can you do boosting and random force
mode at the same time okay
great question random forest mode you
should treat like
a regular old random force no boosting
there are a couple of light gbm
parameters
that you can use to achieve anything on
that spectrum
so there's a parameter called like uh
feature fraction or something like that
that basically says each tree
sample a subset of features but at the
tree level or at the question level of
imagery
um i think it's at the tree level
okay there is a bagging fraction which
is like
sub sample rows at the i think the tree
level
okay and then light gpm does support
uh extremely random treats
which is like totally different kind of
different extremely random trees what's
that
that's uh it's sometimes called extra
trees okay
and it just means that basically i
believe it's one split
is considered per feature and the split
is chosen randomly
okay that's the theory is what it means
is you and this is not like a light
invention there are other packages for
doing extra trees
and what this means is like there is
some guidance in the process
right because once you've selected those
candidate splits the one you pick is
still like
the one with the best game but you don't
exhaustively search the space of all
splits for a feature
and it's like uh so you end up having to
probably use a lot more iterations to
get the same performance
but it's kind of like another type of
regularization right it's like another
way to hold back information from the
model
yep that's pretty cool i'm gonna have to
experiment with your random forest
and speaking of random forest the author
of the random forest package in r
asks um just this person i happen to
recognize him so hi andy
um in what order are the pre-processing
steps done
that is a great question i don't know
the answer to it all right there
i would be happy to like point you to
the relevant you know source code but i
actually don't i actually don't know
the answer to that andy since you wrote
the random force package you want to
grill
james a little bit more about random
forest here just go for it
i'll watch them sweat a little bit
you're already like way beyond the
extent of my knowledge
fair yeah um it is i'll just tell you
really quickly i
i find that people are like a little
surprised sometimes when i talk about
this
they think like when i say that i'm a
maintainer on this project that we all
like
completely understand everything about
light gbm and like
you know that i could like go be like
write
papers that get accepted to machine
learning conferences not at all there's
actually this like
there's like two layers of maintainers
there's me
and a person in moscow who mostly do
kind of software stuff
we like make stuff work with other
versions of cmake and like
build like a ci job to test the cuda
version and
do stuff and then there's like another
layer of people with phds
who change the algorithmic details and
who we
nag to write tests and documentation
inside um andy uh i just wrote in the
chat he feels similarly about
maintaining the lock fit package
he knows very little about his inner
workings
that's good it's a it's a thing it's
every day is an adventure
it's a common model that's why you have
a whole team of people working on the
different parts
yeah for sure um these two questions
seem related
um therefore you have categorical
variables for input
do you need to store them as factors
characters it sounds like you don't need
dummy variables because
how do you store them and then there's a
similar question i'm going to ask both
of the same time
when when you're doing binary outcomes
is your slides
have to be 0 1 but does that mean true
false counts
does that do factors count for that
okay great great questions for both of
those things um
so light gp on none of the light gpm
sort of like public api of the package
accepts data frames today you have to
come with a matrix
or a data set you already created before
and save it into binary format
and so categorical features are encoded
as integers
sort of like the you know as that
integer of a factor something right
so light gpm today is not going to do
that for you so it's not going to make
sure for example that
the integer representation of like a
factor column from your training data
ends up being the same integer levels
for your data you predict them
it's like a known it's a thing it's a
known you know gap a thing that we'd
like to support
um but today you come with integers so
like
if there's a high cardinality then
you're gonna have a bunch of those
integers
um and then light gpm like
in the paper like you know light gpm
describes a bit of
how categorical features are handled
today you should not one hot encode your
categoricals for light tbm
light gpm has an algorithm built into it
for exploring basically
groupings of the categoricals that are
sort of like this group versus
it's kind of like the categorical
equivalent of a continuous split
right in continuous splits it's easy to
consider like here's a number line and
we draw a line and we say like this data
is on the right this is a lot
we kind of do something similar for
categoricals where they're
basically for every level of the feature
the um gradients are computed
and the those levels are sorted by
basically like
what chunk of the gradient you could
address by
just putting all of those together in a
group and then there's like some other
stuff that happens that i don't
understand
and light gbm comes up with its own
groupings of the categoricals
okay and if you i'll tell you one more
thing about that if you read the
original cap boost paper
they kind of like they kind of talk some
smack about that
and they say like this is actually not
great because
those like the only way you compute
gradients right is to know the value of
the target
and they say basically like you're
letting information from the entire
training data
sort of like leak into the way you
encode those
and that's why can't boost does
this other thing here's that picture
this other thing where where for the
same categorical level
you're not going to get the same numeric
value at each instance of it
um can you repeat the second question
about binary classification so if you
have a binary outcome
one of your slides that had to be zero
one labels but um
it looks like it takes a factor so what
a oh sorry it looks like it takes a
vector
so would a factor be good enough or a
vector of true falses
count as zero one so in the r package
today
you're gonna have to come within
basically an integer numeric vector
that is zero and one um
one like piece of adding support for
data frames would be
doing all of that for you right like
like inferring that the things that are
character or factors
are um categorical inferring that the
things that are
posix are numeric and continuous and you
meant to include time stamps like
et cetera et cetera not not supported
today so i think that is one of
you know when i started really working
on this on this r package
three to four years ago the the by far
the majority of the issue volume was
like
i can't install it it's impossible to
install everything's broken and
and it was it was hard it was really
difficult we weren't on cram there's a
lot of other stuff
that has let me knock on wood mostly
gone away with cran
and now i think by far these types of
questions of like i have a data frame
how do i make good choices with light
gbm these are the questions we end up
spending a lot of time on
um and and spending a lot of time
answering but haven't really spent a lot
of time
changing light gbm to address because
of two reasons one is just like very
practically i personally am the person
spending the most time on the art
package and i have been working on the
desk side of the lightsaber package for
the last couple months
um and the light gpm
our packages internals had some other
stuff that had to be dealt with
so if anyone is interested in improving
this we definitely would welcome
welcome conversations and uh welcome the
contributions
that's open source right yeah for sure i
i would like to say one other thing
about that actually you may come to the
repo and find that
um someone recently opened a pr that was
just like
add support for data frames in light gpm
and it kind of touched a lot of code
and kind of took on like four
different things at once like doing
automatically doing the right thing with
features
uh let me give you a column name for the
label instead of a vector of labels like
do this do that
and in a review i asked that person
could we do this in incremental pr's can
we like just import numeric data
then do the like guess at the factors et
cetera et cetera
and that pr the author decided like that
they weren't interested in
working through that and closed it so if
you come to the repo and you see that
please don't think that we're not open
to supporting data frames
um we have a feature request up just
like come say hey i'm interested in
doing this
and we'll kind of guide you on like how
we envision the process going forward
it's cool and
to make your life easier but the
creating integers recipes has a step
integer you can start either at zero or
one
so that's something that could help with
um uh
turning categorical into integers if
anyone needs to use that
yeah cool um okay
for um when you
when you create your lgb.dataset you
provide column names
um as an argument as you project your
column names what if
the matrix had column names already
would that
work i am so glad to finally answer a
question say yes
like because light tbm does the
convenient thing that will help you
yeah so the matrix says column names
they'll be um
basically passed through into the like
feature names parameter
great all right that's an easy one um
can objects saved lgb.save be read by
other lgbt frameworks like um if you had
a c
plus runtime for predictions could you
just load up model that way
yes so that i really like i really like
that question so thank you for whoever
asked that question
that is definitely our aspiration that
be like
one of the benefits that we get from
having the library be one library in c
plus plus with just wrappers
is that sort of interoperability so for
example like
it's going to be dif you're not i don't
think that you can write an aws lambda
function in r
unless you come with your own container
image right you can't just like
use built-ins but what you could do is
train a model in r
produce that text file in you know
format and then
create a python lambda that reads it in
and creates a booster in sports
that is absolutely intended to work i
expect that it works
here's where i tell you that but but
we do not have those types of tests in
the repo today i would love if someone
would come work on those types of tests
so we we have like we've ton we have
like 40 something different continuous
integration jobs
but what we're testing is combinations
of like you know language python r sql
plus whatever
compiler operating system what we're not
testing is like
can i produce a data set or an
or a model object in one language and
use it in another
or could i produce a data center or a
model object in light gpm 3.2.1
and load it with 3.1.0 or vice versa
i would love if someone would come help
us with
with that type of testing we just don't
have it today so
the best i can tell you is like it is
intended to work that way i expect it to
because they're all calling the same
function c plus plus we don't have the
test to give me 100
confidence okay that's great
um oh we have been saying great talk
enjoyed how you plan to
deal with testing by cicd that's
important um
speaking of saving um you mentioned your
talk that you can't use the regular save
rds function because with all the r6
stuff
couldn't you make um this right here
save rds.lgb.booster
like s3 dispatch i guess you're not
using s3 but like someone calls save rds
but it's
when they call it it's really calling
this function
yes probably all right we probably just
should have done that
all right so i i'll let me give you a
little bit more history that might be
hard to figure out from the repo
if you look around in the in the
function names and the structure of the
package
it looks like the x2 boost our package
oh yeah and that's because
it is the x superstar package like
actually boost was released under a
permissive license
and before i started any involvement in
light gpm the first light gpm art
project
was just like change all the xgb's to
lgbs and like
here we go um so for all of these
questions like i want to be sure people
know
when the answer is like no it doesn't
work the way that would be convenient
but we love a contribution
extreme boost would love a contribution
too and would benefit from it
um yeah i think that that could totally
could totally work here's the thing
that's like
here's the thing that's a little weird
about it in case i didn't say it before
right it's that
we create these objects on the c plus
side and what gets returned
are is just a pointer it's just like a
memory address
and making sure that you clean those up
and like
do the right thing in all of the various
ways that an r session
can ask you to remove an object like
directly rmming it restarting your
session
um saving and loading when you shut down
our studio and open it up
it just hasn't really been a focus but
um that is like a very active issue
somebody wrote up a couple days ago so
i'd love help with that so speaking of
that issue
if you're to train a like gbm model in
an
our markdown document that uses caching
on chunks
what's going to happen if a model is
caught in it like you save the model as
mod 1 gets the result of your model and
that's saved in our markdown cache
will that work so no like things like
torch and
tensorflow won't work natively if our
markdown but xgboost does i think
so how would you fit in there that's
interesting i don't actually know how
the our markdown caching mechanism works
if it is just implemented in
environments like if
each chunk becomes an environment then
like they do something
like you know kind of slick about like
getting out of those environments
i would expect light to be able to work
the thing the failure mode for light gbm
is like
you train the model the model has this
pointer to memory that was allocated on
the c
plus side you tear down your r session
and all that memory gets freed
and then you pull back up the model and
that that memory address doesn't contain
a model anymore
so as long as that model is still in
memory even if like
i don't know how the markdown caching
thing works if the markdown caching
thing is like
caching in memory in like different r
environments that might work
i don't know it writes to disk i know
that well then that's not gonna work
yeah i know there's a way like i
experimented with i think
either torch or tensorflow i forget my
favorite one it was i wrote a custom
markdown book
that when it's found on like a that
object instead of saving to the regular
cache it would save it to disk
using like let's let's say it was
tensorflow would save it as like the
tensorflow safe disk object
and read it out like that like i wrote a
very janky custom hook for
our markdown i'm sure a better written
hook will probably do better
yeah i mean possibly and i think that
the s3 idea that someone brought up is a
really good one
um you know in python with this really
nice thing right you just like
create this these under these like
underscore underscore methods and like
when you pickle something
the method gets called it's really easy
to reason about in our
currently we have this functional
interface for save rds and load rds
that's like dispatching with s3 is the
kind of our
way to replicate that i think there's
some
some improvements there and i think um
you should expect a lot of active
development on the art package in the
next couple of months just
we've had these people who've like been
very active asking for things and fixing
things
and i think that's partially been a
result of getting the crayon i think
getting pran we got such wider
we we reduced a lot of friction to end
like barrier sentry
and more people use it and more people
means like weird stuff happens and they
find it so
uh there's a ton of work to be done on
our package we'd love people to come
help out
yeah be on crane that makes it so much
more accessible for sure
for sure so we have andy back uh he
told him to uh to throw some things at
you um if he wants to be able to
traverse the trees in the light gbm
model
is there a way to do that for example
figuring out the path for a particular
data point to go from root to leaf
oh it's so cool yes yes it's awesome
okay there's one thing that i showed and
one thing that i didn't show
um
okay the thing that i showed right i
just want to point out this is a
microsoft project right but you use a
mac
and google slides that's correct all
right just want to point that out
uh yes that is uh absolutely correct yes
uh microsoft project um
i have a windows laptop that actually at
this point i don't do anything else on
it except flight gbm
so it's like eight years old and all it
has on it
is like c make r tools r studio r
and get right let's use it for live tv
and visual studio
and that's like that's it uh yes i'm on
google slides on a mac it's absolutely
correct
um and i actually wrote these slides
working on it i'm going to
204 atlanta okay
um so one thing that you can do is you
can get a data frame
representation of the model where
you know what i've done here is i've
dumped out the first 20
splits from the first table that's just
to make this fit on a slide
you're going to get literally the
description of every single
uh every single node in the tree that is
like the threshold the feature that was
chosen
and then for the leaf nodes you'll get
counts of like how many records match
that leaf node
to get to answer your like more direct
question of how do i see the path
that each node went through light gpm
supports a couple of different
prediction methods uh i'm a little
scared but let's just do this live
because this should be pretty quick
i could go wrong so this is the demo
code that's all up on a repo
so let's just train our model
i think i already uh so what we can do
let's just see if it works
you're a type of like this
thank you
yeah cool okay so let's talk about what
what i just did and let me
zoom up a little bit uh okay
so that's
so light gbm prediction not just in the
r package in any version of the
lightsaber
supports this concept called pred leaf
and what pred leaf is telling you is
each row here represents one observation
in the data that i passed to be
predicted
each column represents one tree
and the number at that cell represents
the
leaf node index that that
record fell into okay so in that table
output right
you had a node index and then like the
split which feature was etcetera
etcetera the depth
if i call this with the training data
instead of this test data
what you could get is for every record
for every tree what leaf node did this
record end up in
so i think that between those two things
you can
get pretty close to like inspecting the
structure of the model
and i'll speak for andy like you measure
putting this in a heat map i guess you
could
see the way uh observations fall i don't
know if that's useful andy but maybe
i like to see cool visualizations of
this this would be pretty cool we would
love
honestly some ideas for visualization
like if people
literally mock something up in google
slides or dry out or something
the visualizations you get with light
gpm today are very
uh simple i i i left that out of the
slides just because like i think you
already saw i was kind of talking fast
near the end
camp boost and actually boost are
definitely more developed in terms of
the
built-in data visualizations that you
can use um
i definitely think there's a lot of
there's the raw pieces here to do some
really interesting stuff we have not put
a lot of focus into data visualization
at all you can get like a bar chart of
future importances
and one other plot that i don't remember
and um and like xg boost has that when
they try to plot multiple trees as one
tree
which i you can't interpret but it's
nice that it's there
for sure and even on the python side of
light gbm
we have some really nice stuff with
graphics um you can look at any one tree
and see it uh like plotted out with the
splits kind of like um
like rattle do people still use rattle i
feel like i learned about randall a long
time ago
i don't know who still uses that i know
it's been around i'm not sure i'm sure
people still use it somewhere yeah well
stuff like that remember how they it
made like the little tree thing with the
feature name
yeah do stuff like that on the python
side of like tbm our we would love if
somebody came in was like
here's some stuff that you should do
that would be cool
[Music]
like uh for instance for you mentioned
variable importance there's a package
called vip which has
s3 methods well maybe it's not always
it's probably s3 um
for these things i'm not sure there is a
um
like gbm method for that but you just
call your vip value for instance xgboost
instead of needing to remember that it's
xgb.variable.importance you just call it
the vfp package
you know on your model um yeah all those
types of integrations i think
would be awesome i mean i i i think like
because we haven't really approached
that a lot we don't have that muscle
built up as reviewers to
like to say here's our clear practice on
when we take on a dependency
versus when we recommend just like
writing a connector library
on the point of feature importances we
do
also support getting feature
contributions for computing
uh shaft values so if you do a
prediction and you use pred contrib
equals true
you are going to get future
contributions
that can be like fed into other shapley
stuff i mean that's like the
way to understand that stuff works um
one other thing while we're here in the
demo up to this point worked
for regression the predictions from the
leaf notes
are going to mostly just be in the terms
of the target
right like we're predicting the price to
charge for this thing
they're in price but for classification
the raw values of the leaf nodes are not
collect predictive classes for examples
they might not even be predictive
probabilities they might be like
you know the value of the loss function
they might be like um i'll put a like
signal function or something right
and so what you can do is raw score
equals true in my gpm
and this says don't do any
post-processing so don't turn
you know like raw um
like raw outputs from classification
into probabilities give me the raw
values of the loss function or whatever
so you can do there's a lot of like
other information that you can get out
of the model and predict
for better for worse is our interface
into that information
nice um there's not a question at all
about
xg boost or light gbm or anything else i
just noticed you have markers tab
on our studio i know i'm sure i'm aware
of markers
to the right right of where you are he
says
whatever this is i either did
accidentally
or is in a very very new version of our
studio
i think it has to do with uh evaluating
your code
like you might have like for like the
debugging on the left like go to line
eight in your code
yeah uh we gotta open this file okay
line eight only use double quotes see
that looks like it's like stuff from
winter
it's linting it yeah i i i did not do
that
now that i wouldn't even notice all
right
and then along those lines perry's
asking um is this a theme for our studio
what theme are you using so it's very
different
yes let me tell you two things about
that one that i learned while creating
this talk
i think that this theme is called the
cobalt theme it's one of the built-in
ones let me check that
um yeah cobalt yeah
i learned something really interesting
doing this talk so i wanted the
um the demo stuff that i put up on
github i wanted anybody to be able
to use it and i want them to be able to
just like run and docker
an image that had our studio cat boost
actually boosted my tbm
and i learned doing that
i'll show you i learned that all of your
r studio preferences are saved in a file
called rstudioprefs i never knew that
before i know like
some people here probably been doing
this for years um
and so what i did is i like ran one of
the base r studio images
because the default settings are nothing
like my settings for example i really
like to have scripts on the left and
console on the right
so that as i like you know command enter
a line i see it run in the console for
example
um but i learned during this talk that i
could just make one of those files
and then just like copy it into the
docker container to the docker image and
put it at the right place
and then when you run when you run
rstudio off this image
it's gonna look the way that i like to
look it's gonna have cobalt it's gonna
strip trailing white space when you save
files gonna like do whatever
yeah that's so cool you could do and
there's actually um i think one of our
last one speaker um uh garrett i think
you're at the rs themes package
which exposes alters like base 16 themes
and they look so beautiful um so it's rs
themes and it's
pre-built themes it comes in like 20 or
30 more themes both light and dark
of all different shades of dark view
parry different like really dark not too
dark
different font they don't control fonts
we get other fonts in here i've seen
some really decked out uh
some things which you could then put in
your preferences json like uh
like you just said that's awesome that's
awesome if no one's ever seen it i mean
you can find this googling just like i
did
but this file is going to be stored at i
think it's dot config
slash rstudio slash rstudio press
nice like home folder slash i didn't do
that this isn't in docker this is on my
laptop
i'm pretty sure this is the rstudio
default for where to put this so
literally i just like change something
save
the file is updated and that's actually
fairly new the the
configuration used to be even harder to
access the file it's fairly new that
they made this nice easy json for you to
get
i want to say within the past 12 months
to make it that easy oh cool yeah i i
just learned about it like literally
this week
that's awesome it's not for this talk
that's awesome
all right i'm going to give you just uh
another soft uh softball you're going to
talking about which way you're going to
toss it
and then something else for you um
you use label as your outcome variable
which seems to really imply
classification you said that
um why'd you go with label
you have to like sorry let me that is
the c plus plus interface of of like why
did i like gbm
make it called label oh i don't know all
right i think it's close to xgboos
it's possible that like it could be that
it's possible that like
target wasn't really in fashion you know
like
have you ever seen like you've ever read
these gradient boosting papers and
they're always like
for example we'll do binary
classification and it's like yeah we
know all these papers only do
classification yeah
left to the as an exercise to the reader
right so i think there's some just like
target wasn't like in fashion maybe
neither was response
response yeah that's but that is total
conjunction on my part i have no idea
and andy is saying you know that's what
the machine learner is calling but yes
but why do they call it label
because it makes it so i think that
regression's an afterthought and they're
only thinking about
classification like we just said yeah i
i personally always like
target i yeah i always like target
i was like train i was trained in
economics and it was just
like response but
i liked saying started to like saying
targets that i could seem cool to my
econ friends
uh and yeah but for like tbm it's gonna
be label it's just like what it is
and andy just said because yeah
regression is usually an afterthought
for them
yeah i think that's just it yeah i
always try to call it an outcome because
that's
perfectly generic yeah hey
i mean you're gonna people are gonna be
upset whatever you choose exactly
yeah you can choose x and y yes yes they
could do that too
all right then lastly there's not a
question there's a comment for me um
actually there's a question
um so i'm a big fan of tiny models and
they also have the built-in
xg boost um oh you see someone's raising
their hand i'm krill i'll get to you in
a second
um i'm a big fan of it you know they
have the interface she boost i know some
people have worked on tree snip which
provides a
cap boost and light gbm interface i know
i've seen that mentioned on your github
repo
um how mature is tree stuff if you're
aware compared to the built-in xg boost
method
for tidy models and is it just sort of
dropping i can just run a bit
i don't know you know i i don't know um
to be honest for me professionally i
have not been writing
r like you know building a model of
consequence for a business
in like two and a half years
so i'm actually like you know i'm
working on the light bmr package
but i'm not like doing day-to-day
applied work in r
so i'm not really actually that familiar
with the ecosystem like
i remember seeing um i think it was max
[ __ ] give a talk about parsnip
at odsc a couple years ago i'm like
familiar with with tidy model stuff
i couldn't comment on how popular those
different things are they think that
xgboost achieves the thing that you're
talking about
they have like a xgboost.carrot
which i think might be the interface
you're talking about that's not how true
parson's working but yeah
i'm interested in this uh where is this
thing
hang on well we're gonna find it now
um okay yeah carrot rapper
maybe i'm wrong i thought that there was
like a
let's just look at this demo i really
thought that there was like a
oh it goes the other direction yeah you
can do carry it and say the method is
actually
okay yeah and tidy model similar thing
with parson
uh you go from tidy models to next g
boost and it basically you know takes
your x and y
and calls d matrix for you i'm imagining
trees smith does something similar
um and i'm a fan of it because like i
managed to use
the um cross validation over the
parameters in parallel my cpu
and then called actual model fitting on
my gpu so it's calling the gpu
repeatedly because the cpu is going
through the iterations
and you let the gpu fit the model each
of the times i got a dramatic speed up
that's awesome i mean yeah we we
definitely welcome it you know i think
on the python side
the story was extremely clear it was
like yeah you have a functional
interface like you know train function
cv function predict function but there's
this huge ecosystem of things that all
implement
the scikit-learn api and here's the
five-page document
on what a a scikit-learn compatible
estimator looks like
i haven't found the same like
universally accepted
thing in our so if you're doing titan
models they have hard hat
right um if you're doing tidy models of
course there's other competing things
there's mlr3
uh carrots put in development mode i
guess mlr3 and tidy models are the two
biggest that i'm aware of
um yeah interesting yeah i mean we
definitely would welcome
i think for that if you're a person who
is interested in seeing that in my tbm
it's not going to happen by me doing it
because i just don't know that much
about it
but if someone comes to us and it's like
here i wish that this code worked
here's here's it it's like here's a
snippet i wish that this worked
can you make it work that'd be actually
a great conversation we'd love to have
that
totally open to it i'll try to um loop
in max to this
like max you gotta you gotta get a like
gpm built in more uh
son of a text sure um i saw karil
raised his hand so i'll give a question
did you plan on asking a question in the
chat thrill or were you just voting on
something agreeing with something of
yours
james was saying earlier let's give a
moment
for that
now there's always that that uh
asymmetric waiting period now and it
looks like curl disappeared from the
participant's list
assumed that girl did not want to see
anything okay so then
i'd like to say thank you very much to
james for this wonderful talk
everyone could give a wonderful uh golf
clap for one second and then
that'll be my golf club um getting some
comments in here people saying it's
awesome i saw some
comments throughout the whole time the q
a saying how great it was saying thank
you to you
um i want to thank you for speaking it's
been wonderful for me i've had a really
great time learning a lot
everyone else did um come around and
stick uh hang out with the rest of our
group james that we're virtual come
come to our meetups come to it um i'm
sure you might find some contributors
here go on our slack and see if you have
any contributors
everybody else uh remember we had the
next three months planned uh
hold on let me tell you what it all was
i don't know
we have july no everything just
disappeared on me
we have june 15th july 13th august 12th
for meetups
july 14-16 for the stem workshop and
announcement coming soon about the new
york r conference
um thank you everybody for attending i
hope you all had a good time
if you have any questions uh james if
you're not on our slack i'm sure they
can find you in your github or something
i'm gonna join the slack tonight perfect
all right if you like
you know feel free to ask questions
there and everyone else i hope you have
a great
rest of your monday i'll see a lot of
you next month and
um hope everyone had a good time thank
you all for coming again once more time
thank you very much james
thank you so much for your time your
questions it was it was great
a lot of fun great all right thank you
everybody have a good night